i think there's also an aspect here that
we should talk about and that is the
impact of of social media that glorifies
the super rich and the x and and
the excess that a lot of people strive
to of course have this kind of
cookie-cutter perfect vision of their
lives when other jobs like you know
manual labor
welders diesel mechanics that kind of
lifestyle is always looked down on i
think there's a programming of our youth
that is absolutely destructive and it
incentivizes the seeking of comfort and
ignoring and pushing away any kind of
discomfort at all costs and portraying
yourself as this perfect amazing image
that has all the filters that looks
perfect that has all the money that has
all the wealth and and when you glorify
and keep repeating that image of what
you're expected to be
when you're given an opportunity to to
work hard too well to be on a farm
psychologically it's not appealing to a
lot of people who just want that perfect
instagram photo who want that
recognition who want that fame without
understanding the hard work that goes
behind it so i think there's another
element uh especially with the
conditioning that happens with the
social media algorithms that needs to be
addressed because i think it is
absolutely destructive towards the
future of this country
have you over the last and sorry
interrupt there be about to launch an
idea over the last hour 20 years you've
been at this 15 17 years or something
what social or the business just the
dirty the dirty stuff dirty job started
20 years ago but i've been i i'm 40
years in this business have you noticed
since the dawning of like the youtuber
that people now just want to be a
youtuber like they don't want to work i
saw a poll and it was like what does the
young kid want to be in america you and
china was astronaut and in america
youtuber yeah i've seen some of that i
don't i don't disagree with you i i look
at it more like an accelerant
than i do
like a prime mover you know like
to me
when american idol hit
that's when i thought you know and and
that that was not a social thing right
that that was a phenomenon that was a
that was a television phenomenon
that that
transparently
uh elevated
idolatry we actually put it in the title
all right it's not american icon
it's american idol all right so we're
gonna we're gonna make fame the thing
the single-minded proposition right and
then we're going to
watch as aspiring dreamers follow their
dream and we're gonna see
how it shakes out there can be only one
right this is like highlander but the
other story of american idol that nobody
talks about
that i find infinitely more interesting
are the number of people who learn for
the first time in their short lives that
they can't sing for crap
all right people who have been told
their entire life that if you have a
dream you can live it all you have to do
is never ever quit if your persistence
were told is enough
to realize your dream lady gaga has said
it i've heard her say it after she won
her academy award i heard beyonce
after grammys
i'm proof little girl that you can
just follow your dream and look what can
happen
well what the hell do they know about
who's listening that's why i told you
before ian i'm stingy with advice
because i don't know who's listening the
odds are very very good that they're
people in that audience that need to
hear the exact opposite they need to be
told it's time to quit
they need to be told staying the course
only makes sense if you're going in the
right direction and if you never tell
people that then you get the first four
or five episodes of american idol which
are very instructive when we see the 21
year old dreamer learn on national
television usually from simon cowell for
the first time in his or her life
that ain't gonna happen for them
now
what does that mean for social when
social comes along it just it just
throws gas on a flame well mike
everyone needs a trophy if they don't
get a trophy we're not all the same and
we're not all equal just like you know
our communist kind of philosophy
overlords who want to push this doctrine
on us that's absolutely insane and calls
for more centralization want us to
believe in so i i kind of wanted to kind
of uh uh ask you
you know
what do you think is leading to this
kind of degradation of of being a
blue-collar worker what what do you
think is some of the leading causes of
of people uh not wanting to do these
hard jobs and then and then wanting to
be the celebrity be always famous so the
most charitable answer and and probably
the truest is just a straight up
honest-to-god
misunderstanding there are stigmas and
stereotypes and myths and misperceptions
that are keeping millions of people from
looking at these trades
of the fourteen hundred people that have
gone through my foundation
hundreds are welding and many many of
them are making north of six figures
this is so common and yet so shocking to
so many people because they've been told
their whole life that that welding
certification or that plumbing
certification or that heating air
conditioning hvac whatever it is
these things have been relegated to
consolation prizes
vocational consolation prizes this is
what you do if you didn't get the degree
this is what you do if you're not the
american idol you get in line you pick
up a welding torch or you pick up the
mallet and you start making little rocks
out of big rocks and that's the
narrative well all of that's wrong
you can make a
wonderful living and you can grow a
meaningful career
by learning a skill and applying it what
would be the first skill you would
suggest or maybe like you said earlier
it's different for everybody i'd have to
know who i was talking to but i can tell
you in general
a lot of people i know
who start welding
wind up with a plumbing certification
and many of them wind up with an
electric certification and many of them
wind up buying a couple of vans and
hiring three or four people and now they
have a mechanical contracting business
nobody talks about the incredible number
of small businesses that begin with the
mastery of a skill not with the
acquisition of a diploma
right i'm not saying that it doesn't
happen that way i'm just saying that we
got really really good at telling one
narrative when when college
got the pr campaign it needed back in
the late 70s we needed more people
going to big schools we needed more
doctors we needed more scientists that
that was real
and the pr push that came with it was
also real the problem is like all pr the
push for college
was
terrible because it came at the expense
of all other forms of education
regarding medicine uh and like
doctorship and stuff i thought that
maybe 12 years is insane and that if
someone can take the test and pass the
test in real time they can do the work
then they're qualified to be the doctor
uh i would love to see that evolution
does that is that something you ever
think about
not much because
because the medical field has it has a
set of challenges that are outside of my
lane but i will tell you just by way of
example i took a a young woman named
chloe hudson on fox and friends about a
month ago she came through our
foundation and she wanted to be a doctor
specifically she wanted to be a plastic
surgeon super super short version of the
story but she was ready to sign on the
dotted line and she was looking at
roughly four hundred thousand dollars in
medical debt over the course of whatever
it was six years
and she just freaked she just said i'm
not i'm not gonna do it so she applies
for a work ethic scholarship from my
foundation
we give her
six seven thousand dollars maybe maybe
you know i we didn't even pay for the
whole thing you know we just helped she
got what she needed though
today four and a half years later she's
making 130 grand a year at joe gibbs
aerospace she's one of their lead
welders
this is a woman who's 28 years old
beautiful defies every pre-existing
concept you have of what a welder is
supposed to look like and she's killing
it she's killing it so
part of my job today is to talk about
all the stuff we're talking about now
but it's also to get chloe hudson on a
billboard to get her on the tv to
suggest to the producers of american
idol that we could have another show
called american icon and we could start
treating
people like chloe hudson
the way the producers of idol treated
adam lambert and that guess what that's
what dirty jobs is for the last 20 years
i treat a sewer inspector the way access
hollywood treats brad pitt
that's my whole
deal whether it's on the foundational
side the missionary side of the
mercenary it would be awesome to have a
show where like they're on stage
building the piping system and then
they've rushed the water through at the
end and see like who could who did it
right see whose pipes hold water yeah
yeah
that's a great show well usually the
blue collar workers are a lot nicer and
a lot cooler than of course even all the
top list celebrities i mean after when
covet hit i was in the middle of new
york city i was like i was done with
this i moved out to new hampshire and i
met an amazing welder and diesel
mechanic named jay noon he also does man
camp up in new hampshire with the free
state project where he goes out and he
literally has all the children from the
community come in from the whole free
state project and says okay we're going
to be building stuff we're going to be
welding stuff we're going to be breaking
stuff down we're going to be building
stuff back up and it's a it's a way to
allow children to look at what they're
passionate about to explore it in real
life and and provide them with an avenue
in a pathway that isn't i'm going to be
a youtuber and let's be honest here when
ish hits the fan when the financial
system is already crumbling and
teetering on disaster those people are
going to be the latest superheroes in a
few years from now when we're dealing
with some serious financial
ramifications because those are the
people that are going to be able to do
something in our society compared to of
course the latte starbucks flip-flop
wearing yuppies who are going to be
wandering around like a horde of zombies
asking for handouts thanks for checking
out this segment from the tim cast irl
podcast if you want to watch live you
can check out this channel monday
through friday at 8 00 pm and don't
forget to smash that like button
subscribe to this channel and if you
want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time